[Music]
uh can I can I can I say uh be cool my
baby does anybody does anybody say that
I want to be a unique voice in late
night does anybody say keep keep cool my
babies is
that is that already taken uh this is
true I I I don't know if who here has
ever hurt their foot and had to wear a
corrective boot does anyone just Round
of Applause a surprising number of you
have had to mend in a corrective boot I
had to do that you have to wear a boot
you hurt your foot that's humiliating
trying to meet girls wearing a
corrective boot just like a sign like no
one breed with this one understand it's
a difficult thing I'll tell you how I
did it I will tell you how you want to
hear the story of how I hurt my foot
here it is I stepped listen I stepped on
some uneven
pavement the story's over that's the end
of the story story that stuff everyone
walks on every day somehow got the best
of meat just an extra inch of sidewalk
jutting up a little bit pretty much too
much of a curveball for the old for the
old pey foot couldn't take it couldn't
take it our bodies are pathetic our foot
it's pathetic it's a pathe have you ever
seen an x-ray of your foot all the
little it looks like a fish skeleton
from a Heathcliff
cartoon you know what I'm talking about
you know what I'm talking about like
in the garbage little Tic Tac bones in
there tiny little Tic Tac bones that
break real easy that's our first line of
defense that's what we send out to meet
the Earth on a little reconnaissance
what's out there send the
foot it's pathetic it's like our whole
bodies are like this powerful beautiful
truck but then our feet are just made
out of the Good China you know what I
mean fragile delicate is what is what
I'm saying are you getting
that and it's not just our feet our
whole our whole body is kind of
ridiculous like think about uh like Star
Wars remember in Star Wars how the Death
Star was impenetrable except it had that
one fatal weak spot yeah we have about
40 of
those your ears your ears hey your
ears you know what it takes to up your
ear just moving up real
fast just like a exceptionally quick
elevator boom pop ruptured ear drump
suddenly you're watching the show with
Clos captioning you understand was was
that
insensitive if that was insensitive
could the close captioning guy uh just
not close caption
that is that okay just just take five
close caption
guy what what yeah
sure what I'm saying is our it's a
miracle you should be grateful that
you're here it's a miracle that you're
here when you consider your neck
you know what's in your neck you know
what right here in your neck
everything life your life source is in
your neck it's all in your neck and
what's protecting it some sort of rib
cage any sort of bone in there
nah just a thin coating of
skin yeah just skin one one ply of skin
just daring the universe tempting the
universe to end your life one Wayward
Arrow
you're a rich guy with a new hobby just
huz you're God it's a miracle your eyes
how precious are your eyes how valuable
is the gift of sight and what is
protecting these just a paper thin
flap right here a paper thin flap that's
open most of the
time at Branch level that's that's nice
how many times have you been walking on
the sidewalk and there's a branch you're
like
Jesus how are we not all blind we should
all be blind there should be one Nimble
person describing what I look like to
the rest of you he's getting redder with
[Music]
time